one time the stones were coming out with
a brand new song so we got on the air
and we said the Rolling Stones we have
their new single we had heard the name
of it was gonna be Harlem shuffle we
stole it from the record company and we
have it and we're gonna move like the
next day now what we had done was we
didn't have the record we heard the name
Harlem shuffle as a cover version so
Fred went into a studio recorded Harlem
shuffle and tried to pretend to be Mick
Jagger decided how they would do it
right so I played it on the air and the
other radio stations immediately
contacted the record company the record
company heard it it sounded so much like
avid stones that they actually
threatened us with lawsuits and sent us
cease and desist orders but this is what
Fred had recorded never hearing the
stones original song
[Music]
so the rival stations were all pissed
off cuz they were like why did you give
Howard Stern that record he doesn't even
play music 1986 we actually did this the
Harlem shuffle hoax they called it
[Music]